negotiation with the Taliban is an issue
that has been much in the press of late
and coverage has probably run much
farther than facts on the ground so far
have warranted the issue itself in terms
of what negotiations mean those
foundational questions haven't been
answered as of yet when how with whom
what are we talking about and so I hope
that today's panel can perhaps shed some
light on on what this should mean
because we're still in a process in a
stage where these questions have not
been answered in any way definitively so
we'll first turn to geo Doron Sora and
he'll get us started
thank you a lot of things have been said
so I'm going to try to give you my
thought about an agreement and
negotiation in Afghanistan right now I
of course it's pessimistic it's my
personal brand
I see three three possibilities
logically first no agreement because the
coalition wins the war
Oh kind of win the war anyway the Kabul
government is able to stand alone and so
we can withdraw without an agreement the
second possibility logically is 12 real
agreement with a political agreement
with the Taliban that is a government of
coalition in Kabul and the third
possibility is what I would call a fake
agreement short-term agreement think
about for example Vietnam 73 I mean the
agreement in Paris and then two years
after of course it's all over that could
be that could be the third default
solution so what is likely what is not
likely what are the consequences of of
all that the first the first situation
would be no agreement and that's the
current position of the
US government means that what is called
an agreement actually is that the
Taliban should should give up their arms
respect the Constitution and be nice
guys forever
okay that's of course not going to
happen but that's the official line of
the US government at the same time you
have the second ID that Karzai should be
in charge of the negotiation and that's
two key points that makes any kind of
diplomatic solution impossible so we are
going to to see that the first thing is
that the trend currently is in favor of
the Taliban in Afghanistan there is no
change in the momentum the crime in
Afghanistan is that your vote of wishful
thinking based on local anecdotes and
Afghanistan is a big country you can
always find a village where things are
going not so bad well it's coming
difficult because it's going difficult
to go to villages but still you can find
a village and I'm afraid of something is
that the current conversation but
Afghanistan is too much about a few
district in the south
what should be clear for everybody is
that even if the current military
operation in the south works and I don't
think it's going to work but even if it
works the momentum is still in favor of
the Taliban because what we have seen in
2010 is the Taliban becoming really I
think a national movement they are
almost everywhere okay they are not in
pancha they are not in Azeroth
but they are mostly a national movement
yes they are mostly Pashtun movement but
you find who's back you find local
communities while working with the
Taliban not necessarily for ideological
reason but for the reasons and that
makes the current situation basically
impossible to a change in the long run
what makes military victory against the
Taliban totally impossible is the fact
that I have the full support of the
Pakistani military and I don't see any
reason why it should change the next
thing the next two years the operation
in South Waziristan or in virtual
audience see whatever we are not ejected
of course against the Afghan Taliban
plus even if the Pakistan we wanted to
fight against the Afghan Terry by don't
think they have enough troops except if
they take troops from the Indian front
Indian border which is not extremely
likely you you have to admit so we are
in a situation where the Taliban are a
long-term player in the political
landscape in Afghanistan that's a
reality so the idea of victory is not
very realistic what we have now it's
another idea actually is the idea that
we have a lot of time because now it's
not even 2014 its tau 2017 2020 the real
deadline with a lot of time we can build
a solid Afghan National Army we'll be
able to contain the Taliban I see to
program with that first problem is that
nothing absolutely nothing indicates
that the Afghan National Army will ever
be able just to contain the Taliban in
most of the provinces all the
information we have goes the other way
think about Lama and resume it's a clear
demonstration that takes a lot of time
to have officials and officials of the
kindy army not the not the soldiers
officers we don't have enough officers
I don't think it could work reasonably
the second point which is extremely
important is that if the endgame is 12 a
government in Kabul which would be
basically like the Najib ULA's
government at the end of the 80s
beginning of the 90s it's not going to
cover the security question on the
afghan-pakistani border so basically we
are going to finance a government with
in control of no region that our
strategic interest for the United States
means if al Qaeda wants to be back in
Afghanistan because I will be back in
Afghanistan I can have training can do
whatever they want so I don't see that
as a very very good solution whatever
which is worse is that the situation
currently is not is not such that you
can even think about the beginning of
withdrawal what's going to happen the
next two four years is that the
Europeans are living whatever we think
about the Europeans as the fighting
forces in Afghanistan the fact is that
we will need to replace them and
concretely what I am saying is that next
September October November some people
are going to say well actually we need
more troops in Afghanistan more US
troops in Afghanistan that's the logical
consequences of less Europeans and most
elements I think it's a kind of
political problem if I'm reading the
situation well and that could be that
could be I mean we will discuss that
later but obviously the idea that we
start we roll we roll in after July 2011
is not going to work so yes we need a
deal we need a deal and you have to kind
of deal basically and the best would be
a government of coalition why because
actually the Taliban are
mostly National Movement and the
Nationalists the relationship with
al-qaeda is weak we can make a deal with
them there is no big problem with with
dealing the Taliban and if we make a
deal with the Taliban we can do content
contact terrorism the frame with the
Biden option is that there was an
elephant in the room that everybody
managed to go around and never touch is
that counterterrorism means a deal with
the Taliban to get the Taliban out of
the picture which is doable locally now
so what are the programs with a
government of coalition the main problem
we have is that we are not back to the
90s means Casa is extremely weak Casa is
not Najibullah sadly enough Casa is not
able to represent yeah I said lean of
certain extent cancer is not about
represent other people from this SB what
that he has very bad relationship we
started in mazar-e-sharif Federation
ship with gusto now of course no support
at all in the Pashtun areas and so what
is Kansai able to represent in a
negotiation and my answer would be not
much so the second option would be to
have not only Karzai but other players
coming from pancha coming from the
northwest who's back whatever to deal
with the Taliban but that suppose at
least two things first that Karzai is
slightly put out of the out of the
negotiation at least he should should
not be the only representative of
Afghanistan the negotiation which is not
easy deal second that should be able to
convince people from the north let's say
Spain speak quickly people from the
north to participate in the negotiation
which is not a given
and third of
that the United States should be part of
the negotiation if you want a
negotiation a solid negotiation in
Afghanistan right now you need to work
the United States out of the process
the idea that you're not just giving a
few planes to - for the transportation
of the Taliban leadership from Quetta to
Kabul is clearly not sufficient so is
that going to work no most probably no
the government of polish and real
political negotiations are going to work
why because first the United State is
not going to bail that option clearly
there is a clear opposition from the US
military at least and even beyond that
to the idea of negotiating with the
Taliban leadership we are still in the
fantasy that we are going to break the
Taliban in little pieces and swallowed
little pieces
it's dreams never going to happen
everybody knows it on the ground
but it's still the official line and
second Obama is not going to take any
risk before the presidential election so
basically we are in a situation where my
bed and I hope very much among my bet is
that nothing is going to move before
2012 2012 the situation we most likely
be a disaster
on the ground and nobody can be sure
that the Taliban and de facto the
Pakistani army will will by a
negotiation
I'm not sure it's too far to predict
anything and last last last option it's
what I call a fake agreement short-term
agreement Vietnam like agreement if you
want the idea that we have the
possibility to exit Afghanistan just
because we need an agreement actually
the same way the Soviet left Afghanistan
with an agreement if every everything
else failed and that is more and more
the likely the likely outcome of the of
the current situation and yeah the idea
that it's possible to withdraw and to
divide the country North against South
is running into a very very deep
difficulties first because if you try to
divide Afghanistan you you could have
very much left in cleansing which is not
a good thing for moral reason and for
political and strategic reason second
your disabilities in Pakistan rot and
third even doing that you still don't
have an answer to your question the
question being how to avoid Afghanistan
being again the base for radical
jihadist movement so I would say that
the main problem we have now is not on
the ground it's in Washington it's how
do you say stop this war is too costly
it's not in the national interest when
you have to situate the political
situation you have in Washington where
there is an over reaction to any kind of
slightly terrorist incident the over
action is killing us killing us
literally where it's not possible
political to say to people there is a
level of risk that we have to accept
because life is like that and zero risk
mean infinite cost that's the problem
from zero issue of the cost is is is
incredibly high so for this reason the
most likely is that the next 18 months 2
years is not going to do anything very
positive then if Obama is re-elected it
will probably be in a better situation
to do something if it's a new president
I'm afraid that you will have IDs and
then we are going to lose one year of
wheels more thank you
okay this is uh this is encouraging
actually because I thought I he wasn't
gonna have any common ground which he'll
actually there's a lot of convergences I
should say that somebody currently
serving in the State Department the
views i express are not necessarily
those of the United States government
and they are my own you know the first
thing is as we discuss Taliban I just
want to sort of frame the issue for
folks again emphasizing that I thought
the term movement was more appropriate
because what you don't see and I was
over with Colonel George in the East and
we were particularly in nangou Honduras
day in Kunar in Lachman which is a
discreet geographic area is that this is
a coherent cohesive you know political
entity the Taliban in fact there were
very few people that would you know
there were a lot of people that were
called Taliban but people had very
divergent affiliations throughout that
area so when you start to talk about who
you're negotiating with I mean it is it
is a question which our moderator raised
right at the beginning who exactly is
that and I think everybody needs to take
that into account that means that the
style and type of negotiation that
you're going to do is going to is going
to rely on a different set of
interlocutors and and one set of
interlocutors based in Quetta or
elsewhere delivering the Taliban is is
basically not going to be possible so
what you're going to have is is a much
more you know a much more nuanced and
and broad conversation with a lot of
different people but but the key is is
all of these other factions these other
criminal networks that are out there and
then really understanding that a lot of
the conflict is locally driven and so
again one of the things that Gio
identified is that not everything is
ideological and it is in areas that the
conflict is not ideological that it may
be straight political or economic
in nature that we have the opportunity
to explore a way forward and I think
that's very important for folks to
understand because it's only the very
narrow ideological conflict against the
West you know in support of
transnational sub state actors that is
you know our red line and so the big
thing is is that you know local
accommodation and community equities
have to be taken into account so you
know in the areas that we were operating
I'll discuss this just a little bit more
in depth you know people had some some
basic asks of how they were able to
better interact with their own
government and finding ways to address
those concerns can mitigate conflict in
a way and create some traction for the
state that will be drawn in sharp
contrast with what the Taliban is trying
to put out in order for any sort of
negotiations on reconciliation of
reintegration to be successful though
the relationship between the center and
the periphery is going to have to be
better defined and the narratives are
going to have to be synchronized and
what I mean by that is is what is
happening in Kabul in terms of
reconciliation is not necessarily what's
happening at the district level and
we've got to find a way to make sure
that the districts are on the same page
as the province which is on the same
page as Kabul and in terms of the
narratives you know is it a political
war is it an ideological war and who is
the war against so you know as one
example of that soldiers who are serving
in the Afghan government in the in the
Afghan National Army expressed concern
to us that they said look every day we
are fighting folks that are
ideologically aligned with the Taliban
and then we see that the negotiation is
all about the Taliban and not
necessarily about our local concerns and
that concerns us because we're trying to
support the state and so that narrative
has to come together and then the last
point
I actually agree with Zeile again is
that you know red lines remain for the
West in terms of the affiliation with
al-qaeda or other other groups and so
that will have to be taken into account
but all of that adds up to elements that
make up a negotiation strategy so you
know I think that while it's very easy
to sit back and say okay nothing is
working and and everything's falling
apart actually if you do have those
elements in place and if people are
considering them which in fact they are
you do have the opportunity to move
forward and that change can happen very
quickly on the ground I think that you
know in highly kinetic environments
people can get it's very easy to get
pessimistic you see a lot of people
dying you see a lot of problems but you
know wars do end and the way they end is
often through negotiation let me just I
just want to give folks a little bit of
a sense of what the current structure is
because in Afghanistan the way is F and
the Afghan government have defined
reconciliation reintegration is a bit
different than other parts of the world
you know it's not a traditional DDR our
structure they literally come up with a
definition where reconciliation is a
high level between the Karzai government
and you know let's say Taliban or others
and reintegration is really everybody
who is not a senior senior decision
maker and is a mid-level commander and
and in fact ICF's guidance to troops is
to support Afghan government efforts at
reintegration on the ground so I would
distinguish a little bit when you say
that the military is absolutely against
any sort of negotiations on the ground
and is looking for an absolute some sort
of kinetic military victory in fact it's
a much more pragmatic approach and
that's that's part of what defines the
counterinsurgency strategy this
two-tiered approach however you know
requires some caution because there have
been a lot of disarmament programs in
Afghanistan over the last
years you know including the disarmament
of the illegal armed groups effort and
several other efforts that have been put
forward the challenge there is that
ordinarily in a wartime situation you
have some sort of peace settlement some
sort of political accommodation and then
that's followed by a reconciliation
process in other words reconciliation is
the process of after you've agreed to
stop shooting you're bringing folks back
into the government and and that's
usually paired with a DDR armed process
where you know you actually have
specific armed groups and then there
demobilized disarmed rehabilitated and
reintegrated and those sometimes one
happens and the other doesn't happen it
really depends on the nature of the
conflict you know in Afghanistan the
challenges they're trying to do several
of these things at once so they're
actually trying to do a reintegration
program or put it forward while in a
kinetic war and we don't have the full
political settlement yet and I think
that's that's a bit of a challenge and
how you implement because what happens
is some folks want to move forward with
programs and it's not going to take a
programmatic end to the to the war the
other thing is is that what we're also
dealing with is is a conflict that is
really characterized by ambivalence
toward the state and the challenge is is
getting communities fully vested in the
state and fully supporting in the state
and that's where you know Colonel George
talked about whether it's tribal
engagement or local engagement bringing
various constituencies that may feel
that they don't have or not receiving
the benefits of participation bringing
them back into the political discourse
and when that kind of initiative happens
you have a far better chance that they
will not take a purely ideological view
of the war and so solutions exist for
making that happen you know one is I
know local or village elections are
somewhat down the line but that is
something that is slated for the future
the district election process
understanding grievances and finding
ways to mitigate the challenges that are
raised when people disagree with
appointments in the unitary state system
and understanding the grievances coming
out of communities and and forcefully
and quickly addressing them gives you an
opportunity to provide a more responsive
government so you know again solutions
are out there it's a question of the
commitment to follow through and then
you know finally there's also
understanding the need again the
localized nature of the conflict in a
lot of cases it has to do with revenue
streams so you know in places like Kunar
you have tim timber gems and other
sources of revenue that the central
government essentially is looking to
make sure that one those are controlled
for you know obvious environmental
reasons but the other reason is of
course folks are trying to get a handle
on that revenue stream
finding ways to address local concerns
so that people who work in those
industries who work on timber or who
trade in gems are able to benefit from
that without being in conflict with the
state is something that can be done and
it's something that people are working
on so again there are avenues to tamp
down conflict and then that in a
circumstance like that and we've seen
this in places like Nora Stan people are
then less inclined to look to an
outsider an ideological person coming in
such as a Taliban who's crossed over
from Pakistan and decides that he wants
to establish himself in a particular
area and more likely to look to their
own their own resources and their own
relationship with the government you
know a couple examples of this that we
saw in one case was up in Norris Stan it
was an area that you know we've gotten
into conflict with Hague in the past and
you know there was a a mullah up there
that we had actually been in active
conflict with and you know part of that
to do with the nature of our
relationships with various folks in the
center and you know over time it became
clear that you know he did not want to
go the route of the Taliban and at least
signal to us that there was a
willingness to potentially break from
you know transnational terrorism and in
that case it opens up an opportunity for
us to go in and re-engage him what were
the asks he asks on his side were both
for the US military one to stop
targeting him okay but that required
concurrence also with the Afghan
military and everything but the second
thing is is actually putting you know
having some input from his local Shura
into who gets to be you know the
minister the line Minister for Education
who gets to be the sub governor who's
the police police chief and and you know
it's very easy to write this this off as
well that's warlordism and that's a
return to warlordism but at the same
time you know the alternatives are that
folks that are funded and financed by
exogenous forces and have an ideological
disposition very much against the
international effort come into that area
and and take over some of that area and
the interesting thing is is that to
support somebody like that does not
necessarily require a large military
presence it doesn't require a you know
robust even a development agenda what it
requires is to try to again connect what
the center is doing with what's going on
out in the periphery and make sure that
they're understanding and hearing those
concerns and relaying that back and
that's sort of you know you know it's a
there's a counterinsurgency element to
it but it's also classic diplomacy but
what it what it does is it takes us out
of the conflict and it puts us in a more
facilitative role and interestingly you
know what I saw when I was over there
for a year is a lot of people were not
fully against the international effort
in fact they were quite favorable to our
involvement what they didn't like though
was a lot of elements that were
happening in their own government and
they felt that we were also misusing our
resources and things
so understanding where those concerns
are coming from is a way to advance the
effort similarly you know Nanga har you
know can can easily be I mean it is the
prize for the east of Afghanistan
you've got Jalalabad you have the Khyber
Pass you have a huge amount of resources
and wealth flowing through that area and
you know in Jalalabad there's there's a
lot of different equities there there's
a lot of different interests there's
business communities there's you know
trade and you know there's there's
tribal interests and agriculture and all
of that comes together which gives
people a reason not to necessarily
perpetuate conflict and in a lot of ways
you could argue okay that's that's
probably why the moment have generally
chosen to side with the government
they're they're they're getting more
benefit by being part of the state than
being in opposition to it same thing
with the Shinhwa right and the co gianni
though have had more of a difficult
relationship because there has been a
return of some of the poppy crops and
things like that but I would contest
that you know poppy is the only way to
make money there's a lot of different
ways to make money and it's making sure
that people have access to that and
again you can look at things like local
revenue generation and taxation and and
changes like that can show that the
state is more responsive so the
possibility is out there so again the
final thing though I want to say is that
you know for us to continue to make
progress it means to make sure that
we're not involved in parochial disputes
that we shouldn't be involved in make
sure that we're not siding with folks
that really are not aligned against us
but are aligned against each other and
we're not getting played off off of
themselves and and that has happened in
the past and I think we have a far
better understanding on the ground of
that now that we don't necessarily need
to be involved in every land dispute but
what we can do is help listen and
connect that back to the the center and
then again synchronizing the narratives
making sure that if we're doing
reintegration efforts on the ground and
there is a mullah sadiq out there or
a you know a math tune or other players
out there that are local characters that
have local influence and we want a
dialogue with them and we want the
Afghan government on the ground to
dialogue with them that there's
political support back in Kabul because
there's a lot of different interests as
people have talked about the Northern
Alliance and and other folks have their
equities the posture and have their
equities but that discussion is taking
place and that's why you know there's I
don't think you can look at it and say
that it's it's all about to come apart
all of these different interests are
there and in fact the one thing we can
say is is that you know the country is
people say well there's only 38% you
know literacy and there's all that all
of those things though have advanced
significantly in in the last ten years I
mean the time that it takes to get to
medical treatment from northern Kunar
down to Jalalabad has been you know cut
significantly the roads are there the
trade is there the opportunity for
economic progress and then there's a lot
more in the world with the globalization
of small trade things so opportunities
exist out there for negotiation and
we'll see how it plays out I mean it'd
be a disaster at this time of day if we
find the panel agreeing with each other
so if I don't if I don't directly want
to contradict my esteemed colleagues I
guess I can say it differently so as
they've been so eloquent I can start
with a cliche and the the cliche the
cliche I wanted to start with was in
time-honored fashion taking us back to
the asymmetry of 19th century and early
20th century warfare in the same area
where warfare is being played out today
and remember you can I mean your media
you can remember which cliche I'm
talking about I'm talking about
arithmetic on the frontier remember it
most people should remember it it's you
know a scrimmage on a border station a
counter down a dark defile 2,000 pounds
of Education drops to a 10 rupee Giselle
the Crammers boasts the squadron
pride shot like a rubber tanned a ride
now what was the I mean was the
imbalance the imbalance there of the
amount of investment that went into a
British officer and the amount of money
it took to to make a home made Giselle
rifle to shoot him with they to keep to
keep us awake I wanted to just to start
actually start off with a question again
somebody mentioned earlier on this is a
university if we're just thinking in
terms of a asymmetries today I mean the
Taliban are at the moment the enemy and
there are roundabouts about ten thousand
of the enemy in the field fighting
against the US and all the u.s. is
allies how much how much does it cost us
her enemy per year how many zeros just
off the edge again good or with my
mental arithmetic how many zeros per
enemy for us to take on yeah okay
seven seven zeros ten million dollars
per enemy is the in the annual
investment with the current with the
current approach and with the current
choice of enemy so moving from moving
from cliche cliche to question to
confession and the confession is again
I've got to sign up I've got to sign up
in the optimist camp however I'm one of
those optimists who actually goes around
with a few reasons for his optimism they
they I mean obviously the basic the
basic optimism that I'm offering is that
it is possible to achieve an Afghanistan
which is peaceful stable and yeah not a
imminent threat to anybody and an
outcome which broadly would be good for
the people of Afghanistan for the people
of the region and the people of the
United States of the various factors
that we can call into play for this
optimism the first is if you sound out
multiple constituencies
seas around Afghanistan despite the
fairly appalling situation and
trajectory I mean the idea of peace
actually has an awful lot of takers with
this I mean I sorry man I know I do not
believe that there is an empirical basis
to any assertion that so you know they
Afghans are okay with perpetual conflict
there is a strong constituency for peace
but at the moment it does obviously not
manage to have adequate leverage on the
political military developments in the
country and along with this general
sentiment this general sentiment for
peace that I think if you went out there
you get plenty of indicators to come up
with it the idea of Afghanistan itself
you had again you know multiple
references saying that the idea of the
idea of it Afghanistan itself despite 30
years of conflict is is very strong
there is no strong no strong
constituency in Afghanistan which is
against the idea of Afghanistan or in
favor of something which would look like
breakup there's oh there's also I mean
in terms of ideas of governance ideas of
the state you know there's not too much
zero Sun out there and many of the I
mean there is we have here lots of
people talking about you know a desire
for a strong central state but then it's
also combined with actual ideas for
forms of local autonomy which more about
you know achieving justice at the local
area without and not really expecting to
sneer at too much state interference in
achieving that in other words in terms
of the the what what you're dealing with
in terms of many many people's ideas are
compatible with so the the end state and
that I think that many of us would like
to achieve there's also I mean there's
also the show course which on our on our
today's panel to do with the Taliban the
people that we've chosen as our you know
10 million dollar each enemy have been
systematically miss portrayed over the
past few years as a far more of a threat
than they actually are they're not
actually quite as dangerous as we have
had to portray them so as
to sustain the narrative for the current
stage of the conflict and significant
early on we talked about rebranding of
Pakistan rebranding the part rebranding
the Taliban is perhaps not quite as
difficult I do not think mere that you
know this this should not be taken as a
sort of a your head in the stands of
position that we also we should
acknowledge that currently the Taliban
movement represents the main the the
main force inside the armed opposition
in arms against
a government which arose out of a United
Nations backed process a process which I
certainly would contend had a great deal
of support on the ground inside
Afghanistan and which you know in their
prime attic terms is supported by the
United States so there should be any
surprise that currently they are the
Taliban they are the enemy are being
fought against by saying there is
nothing inevitable about it and that the
the final the final bit of optimism or
the REIT in the other the basis for the
optimism is this one of these rare
planetary alignments the astronomers
hang out for decades to get when we find
that they the fiscal argument and the
idealist argument Alliance because
broadly what to to achieve the the
acceptable and attainable end state
which I've been talking about rather
less money is going to be required than
war and probably less boots on the
ground rather than more I mean there's
gonna be a lot of subtlety a lot of
politics a certain amount of agony and
may take quite a while but broadly the
idealist position fortunately costs less
and given that they the current economic
circumstances and those projected for
the next few years that argument may end
up counting for rather more incoming
years than in previous years so going
from the I mean trying to obviously to
on to go to go from this a broad
position of idealist and broad ideas of
why we should be there if we are trying
to tackle they tackle the issue of you
know the Taliban and how do we get them
out of their privileged $10,000,000
position I mean there's a sort of eight
you know a Taliban ology has been
being over the past few years people are
trying to you know to grapple with the
issue of what an earth they are about
and how do we use this knowledge about
what they are about to inform what has
to be done so I mean yeah if we had all
day I've got on your list as list as
long as your arm of the kind of
interesting questions one could ask
about the Taliban and reach conclusions
about what is to be done
I mean I'd only get through a couple of
them but of course we generally start we
generally start with asking you know
broadly what is it did the Taliban want
and you know quite often you can just
get onto a website when you want to
watch the workout what a movement is is
about and you read the thing and you and
you memorize it and that's it but of
course the thing is that yeah it's not
quite as simple as that because they you
know the Taliban is the Taliban is far
more than just a simply hierarchically
organized movement that you look at the
top of the hierarchy and that tells you
what the whole movement is about that
they even when you talk to Taliban foot
soldiers whereas I mean in reality they
exercises a fair degree of autonomy in
the areas where they operate they say
but we do listen to what our official
spokesman says and it does influence us
some way so basically in trying to
understand there's I mean there's a you
know there is a sort of stargazing game
involved there trying to work out what
the Taliban are banned there's no single
text and there's no authoritative text
which you can say really defines what's
drives the movement because there is an
awful lot of position play and a lot of
the this is what has put out in the
airwaves and the propaganda is
convenient there as part of the
informational war but does not really
define what actually is driving the the
conflict so yeah how yeah there's a
complex basis as how you're rising seas
but I think some of the things that I
think we could we could justify and
saying that the Taliban do actually
stand for is that they do stand for
foreign troops out and you know lots of
evidence I mean just you know whether
you look at the propaganda they put out
at the top or whether you look to people
down there at the bottom Iraqis doing
the fighting this certainly does come
out of there of course the end was one
of the reasons for alignment is that
probably you know converges with
probably
quite a few of the people in this room
and many of the decision makers in
Washington and other Western and western
capitals but I mean still yeah yeah the
movement does have an awful lot to do
with wanting foreign troops out and
although in many of their official
positions they don't really spell out
what it means operationally actually the
movement is something about the
attainment of an ideal Islamic society
they've generally despite the fact that
you know in another era when they were
in power you know one click
pursued a very interesting project in
building an Islamic state most them
didn't know much about the legislative
program and I don't think we can really
say that that's what drives the current
fighters but even when you look both at
members of the leadership and with
people on the ground there are ideas of
justice are driving it and when they
express those ideas of justice they've
always put an Islamic label may because
there's a sort of an assumption of
convergence that you know inherently a
just society is bound to be an Islamic
society that's if you look from the
perspective of Kandahar or Nanga har
east of Afghanistan or west of
Afghanistan those those things are more
obviously synonymous than when you're
looking from a New York or Washington
perspective there's in there along with
justice in their idea of the Islamic
society that they're striving for
there's something to do with public
piety I mean that a the society that
we're striving for which would be just
should also look Islamic how many people
should be saying their prayers and so on
the public public piety will be observed
and again they don't actually did
actually express this in any propaganda
piece or in any piece of writing but
this is something which is more or less
yeah yeah it's a political come
anthropological observation they stand
for respect for the clergy at least
their brand of the currency clearly I
mean yeah those clergy who become
collaborators I mean they take them on
ruthlessly and kill them but the
movement has sprung out of a tradition
of saying it we the clergy are the
vanguard of the vanguard of the right
kind of politics and also as is clear
and much of their local politics and
some of their public stance
even in some of their at their
propaganda they sound broadly against
corruption even against the illegal
accumulation of wealth I mean funny
enough many of the statements that we
get weather and wiki wiki leaks or the
New York Times or whatever our
statements which they're generally
attributed to US diplomats but I mean if
we did a Taliban WikiLeaks we could
probably actually get them saying many
of the same things themselves they again
they don't they avoid articulating this
and so in deal in writing but it's clear
from the discourse and if you sit down
you know sit down with the people who
actually count inside the movement you
know guess what it's not just that
yeah like sociologically speaking they
are Pashtuns
that they the movement tends to assert
the primacy of Pashtuns
in Afghan politics and there are ideas
are trying to redress the unnatural
imbalance which has arisen over the past
few years that with many and many of our
students believing that somehow they
have been displaced to what a relative
to their natural equilibrium I mean I
think that they I mean if I had to come
up with a with a phrase that that summed
up you know who the Taliban are
politically it would be that they are
the clerical wing of traditional push to
nationalism which probably isn't
terribly terrifying actually
because mechanically the next part is it
clearly they are Afghan nationalists and
Afghan the Afghan nationalist idli as
expressed by this in traditional this
this clerical part of traditional Pashtu
nationalism is about it they generally
would you know their political instincts
are in favor of some kind of role for
central government that anybody who says
anything nice and well-informed about
decentralization federalism
instinctively they're against it
although they might not have many clear
ideas about what to do about it
quickly they're in favor of the notion
of of central government and that
they're they tend to be yeah yeah a
highly sensitive about foreign
interference and foreign presence in
Afghanistan but this is not from a new
21st century revival of your anti u.s.
stance this is something inherited from
19th century Afghan polity
before the United States was a force in
the area suspicion about any any foreign
involvement and in Afghanistan
it's a traditional political instinct
and rather something which is emerged at
the global jihad and in you know in the
politics of today of course they are
there's an anti collaborationists
anybody who's involved in clear
association with they witness at the
United States engagement in Afghanistan
then currently the Taliban have to be
against them and position your position
themselves of being against them and can
lambaste people for their proximity to
this of the International project inside
Afghanistan so although I mean the kind
of things that they're in favor doesn't
make them terribly easy people to deal
with if you are either a non unknown
talent in Afghan politics or you if
you're an international player trying to
work now that we've got in how do we
achieve some kind of stability but at
least in terms of the basic thing they
don't necessarily merit that 10 million
dollar position that yeah this makes
them this establishes them as Afghan
political actors par excellence but not
not permanent enemies of the United
States one of the issues that we had
cropping up earlier on I'm going to be
not not going to go answer the whole
list of the whole list of questions we
did at least have the the issue before
lunch about what about the point that
the Taliban are not a monolithic
organization and what are the
implications of this for reconciliation
strategy and of course with you think
back to people's in a description of how
the Taliban are organized at the moment
they'll give you the the Creta sure and
the a what was the and we had the
initials it was me okay st yeah okay so
you know the KS t Crichton you know the
Quetta Shura they they are the original
Taliban movement formed in 1994 led by
mullah omar based upon a political
heritage that went back at least in 1978
when young men who were the young
generation of clerics became some of the
the vanguard of the jihad against the
Communists and then against the Soviets
and later on coalesced as they formally
declared political move
and took over the country and that's
yeah that's one part of the Taliban
movement and I mean in a sense there yet
they really are important and the reason
the reason that people refer to the
insurgency and the Taliban as almost
synonymous although the fine-tuned
descriptions say they're not is because
that movement did actually capture most
of the country was internationally very
visible and you can have a claim to be
trying to build an Islamic state and so
in a sense they're important not just as
movement in which you can decide whether
you know whether someone belongs to a
movement or doesn't belong to move it
supports murder doesn't they're
important as the holders of a brand that
they are you know that they are this is
the symbol of you know those who were
thrown out by the Americans that will
not now fight back and of course who
have you know striven striven for
achieving a and Islamic society now if I
were if I were to the like the legal
adviser to the Quetta Shura I would
actually be talking to the leadership at
the moment I would be saying you know we
really have to watch our intellectual
property rights in fact I think are we
really have to contemplate legal action
against the Haqqani network because in
terms of significance in Afghan politics
I mean that you know the Taliban
movement they're seeing from this in you
know the same place where are they in
1747 as the Afghan state was born they
are we have they are members of tribes
even if there tend to be some severe you
know poor boys from those tries but
tribes have got a well-known place in
politics who can or each of which tribe
can remember those those of their tribe
who have held significant power
positions in Afghan politics the Haqqani
czar Hillbillies I mean there are people
from a insignificant border tribe that
only only only ever plays a role in
Afghan politics temporarily during times
of crisis and never plays a significant
role in actually governing the country
and yet over the past year or two there
has been this attempt by the people in
sitting in the car in the Haqqani
network and their backers to appropriate
brand Talib except
garage the easing out of the word Talib
and they're going back to Islamic
Emirate of Afghanistan so they're trying
to that they're trying to create an
image that we can be a you know we can
be a movement which tries to take over
Afghanistan and it's not actually driven
by the people who read through the led
the movement in 1994 now all this is are
like great stuff for the analysts who
trying to work out what's going going on
there actually are very some very
significant implications for those
people to say okay probably the way
forward is helping the Taliban out of
the you know that ten million dollar
position into not being enemies of the
United States and probably being in
partners partners in some kind of a
solution it is quite it is quite
possible that some kind of deal of the
kind of thing that was yield was saying
is might not be impossible might might
not be unattainable that the some of the
original leadership of the the Kandahar
II Taliban some of those people who were
part of that movement sufficient
sufficient to actually you say that we
are the Taliban movement not snow not
the rump not a split part of it not a
few people brought in you know in the
dead of night through an innate in NATO
aircraft but IT the Taliban movement are
actually are actually part of this
process that they it is conceivable if
the kind of the kind of deal was geela
saying you know not easy not on the
current trajectory but might might
actually happen that if these if the
Taliban movement actually owned the
process because they were convinced that
it was actually in keeping with what
they what they stood for as in movement
and was not actually leading to the
legitimation of the the presence of
foreign troops but actually leading to
the towards the end the the end of a the
foreign troop presence but to some kind
of negotiated way as to how Afghans
would live live inside the same state
and how they would relate to the
international community and how they
will probably cooperate in rebuilding
the country it is possible then of that
kind of deal that the other parts of the
current insurgency would be against it
and so yeah that's that's about how you
structure the deal how you structure the
engagement the
what happens afterwards and also
accepting that it's possible that's
something which would look like a deal
wouldn't instantly be achieved peace but
would be an important milestone on the
way to peace and would be the you know
the start of the process of solving this
riddle of the the ten million dollar
enemy of turning people who are
currently this is near the sequels of
that ten rupee Giselle and since it said
engaging them as social capital the kind
of you know taking on some of the you
know the values and their ability to
mobilize people to make the process
succeed rather than end the process but
I mean think they sort of the funneling
implication that you get from it is that
what happens in the intra Taliban intra
insurgent politics does actually have
significance for whether you make
progress on stability or not and the bad
old days where we sort of treated all
insurgents the same we're probably and
never going to get us out there but
there's gonna have to be a lot more
subtlety of politics as you go forward
and I mean I personally have observed
over over the past year I've been amazed
at words you know some of our friends
have talked about how al-qaeda has no
presence in Afghanistan in some parts of
the insurgency the the nexus between
international militants the Pakistani
Taliban movement and Afghan insurgents
has grown stronger
rather than weaker the number of non
Afghan elements actively engaged in the
insurgency has increased not reduced and
broadly I think that the more that
happens the more difficult it is to
achieve stability and to a G on to
enable Taliban social capital to be
deployed in making this thing work than
not
so definitely anybody working for
stability wants to watch that process
and find subtle ways on essentially you
know reversing it and probably makes you
all the more keen to incentive to engage
the official Taliban get them on board
and achieve what is I believe is
achievable which is a peaceful stable
Afghanistan which is the best outcome
for Afghanistan the region and the US
well picking up
on this before I open it up to the floor
for questions you talked about the
shifting dynamics within the movement
and there has been some consistent talk
about generational shifts to a younger
more radicalized less politicized cadre
of mid-level commanders is there a sense
that to any of the panelists is there a
sense that there's a time limit a window
of opportunity that might be missed is
is the sort of dynamics of war going to
create a more radicalized movement if if
there's no serious engagement in in the
near term what Michael was saying
actually was a little bit too indirect
I'm going to say moderately what you
wanted to say actually is that if you if
we keep killing the Taliban we have a
kind of what kind of no table if working
everybody with over 35 years old because
they run this less well than the young
people we will have a much more
radicalized movement and that's probably
what we are seeing in Canada so they are
two different sort of things things we
we don't we cannot manage we cannot
impact what's going on in north
waziristan is difficult to do something
about but the current strategy the way
it works I think is pushing the Taliban
in to direction that are bad first they
are more radicalized and maybe just
maybe the central leadership is less
able to to control its it's militants so
that's I'm afraid of that so if we could
take questions I could come to the edges
sorry I just want to here look again in
the east in the areas that Colonel
George and I served what we did not see
was this Taliban movement there's a lot
of people who call themselves Talib's
but the political leaning
and the conflict with the state the
Taliban were associated with criminal
networks that were doing the drugs
elsewhere it was a couple folks that
were really trying to assert greater
authority in the Kunar area but the but
the differences within those movements
were great and you know I actually do
think it gets to what Michael had talked
about which is that you know the
overwhelming desire of the the people
that we encountered was certainly to
live with in a more secure state and
they did not associate that with Taliban
so you know that's four provinces I
would argue that there were a host more
of provinces and again I'm not going to
speak to the South I'm not going to
speak to the ideological Heartland and
places like that but I you know I can
say that you know we can overplay it and
and and give more prominence to to this
this group and what we really have to
understand is look if the state is
working for the majority of the people
then all the radicalism in the world
doesn't really help because communities
themselves will turn away these
insurgents and sometimes they need help
doing that and that's where we can come
in and and you know provide assistance
but what we want to make sure is that
the grievances with the state itself are
addressed and when those grievances are
addressed then they don't let Taliban
into their communities or let's call
them folks that are ideologically
completely against the state so so we
can take some questions if you could
come up to the microphone and state your
name and affiliation John Koch I'm a
political scientist but my
specialization is East Asia rather than
Central Asia I have two very simple
observations one of which makes me
optimistic the other makes me
pessimistic the option on the optimistic
side
you have a government which is basically
a foreign creation and it's fighting for
subtraction but unlike Vietnam for
example there's no milk Viet Cong out
there which had popular following so
that makes me optimistic what makes me
pessimistic is I don't see the common
ground between the Taliban and the
government I don't think they're
speaking the same language so if a
strategy is just simply to keep mowing
them down as they come forward and
eventually exhausting me that you don't
really have a negotiating strategy it's
simply a military strategy of extinct it
takes think extinguishing the enemy so
to speak so that's the pessimistic side
what is the common glue that is going to
produce a successful negotiation
assuming that this government because it
doesn't really have any competition
other than this node this military force
I think the the common glue which will
bind this together if it all works out
is essentially the idea of Afghanistan
that they when you know when you want to
do the empirics of this it is important
to look at the what drives the what
drives the Taliban and yeah they've got
they have got aspirations which are
largely confined to Afghanistan they of
course they consider many of the other
the people who are either in the
government or behind the government they
consider themselves iddah them as civil
war foes so that they they saw that yeah
they accept that we are against them but
they also understand that they are
competing for the same this
the same space and that they I mean
there's a lot of questions about this
this whole issue of this whole issue of
is there any element of war fatigue
inside the the Taliban and it's been
it's been sometimes overplayed and
sometimes under played yeah that they
yeah and the so the zenith of the over
play was the server around this is the
other fake after Mahmoud Mansour this
notion that the the Taliban are so
absolutely fed up they want they're
ready to to throw the towel in and and
you negotiate a ceasefire now that was
over playing the extent to which there
is fatigue but I mean I know on the
basis of multiple discussions with
people's reasonably well placed inside
the movement that there is a strong
tendency inside inside the movement that
you know does not want to sustain the
conflict indefinitely and is not
convinced that they that they are going
to fight their way into control of the
whole of the country in the foreseeable
future but these things change and that
they the more that it looks that looks
as if actually the time that they the
Karzai government is about to collapse
and this is the the u.s. strategy
absolutely not going to work and the
more that those people who thought oh
that you know we actually are going to
have to you know we've been have to
negotiate our desires for Afghanistan
with the other Afghan political players
they take a backseat and said let the
military fight on because will you guess
what we can negotiate while we're in a
stronger position and when we've beaten
the American us so they what what holds
them together is that they are actually
looking at the same this the same
political space and that they there are
tendencies on both sides which except
we're going to have to share this space
but yeah this is their this particular
painting is not yet ready and there are
some there are some on the other side
who think they can persuade the are the
Americans to keep on fighting this war
indefinitely and there are some won the
Taliban side who do believe that here
one more push we cannot just push the
Americans out but we can actually subdue
other Afghans so why don't we take the
next three questions together thank you
my name is Portia I would like to ask
you about me but what you would consider
a potential role for the United Nations
through the Special Representative to
the Secretary General in any
negotiations with the Taliban and I
understand that the answer to this
question really depends on what you hope
to accomplish with these negotiations
but assuming that a man were to get some
sort of Taliban representation in the
Karzai government some sort of wait for
them to articulate politically their
demands
Saburo Brahimi I'm a visiting student
from New Jersey first of all I want to
the panel to kind of elaborate a little
bit more about what do they mean by
Taliban Taliban ISM being an Afghan
nationalist movement because I'm not
gonna I didn't believe in that secondly
about the grievances of the Afghans and
the communities and villages it is it is
an issue and it has been realized by the
panel but like a lot of the programs or
the projects that are underway in
Afghanistan to kind of meet the needs of
those communities are short or not
something sustainable what are your
suggestions for long term and
sustainable development for those
communities rather than short-term
projects I cost to me as an Afghans
sometimes I see us like bribing the
community to just keep quiet for a while
and then once the money Spanish day
again started you know going back to the
Taliban and trying to create problem in
order to get more money from you
so yeah fantastic Amadis I teach here
and I also write about the Middle East
I'm curious about how you guys assess
the natural equilibrium of the Taliban
and its other Afghan counterparts often
referred in his remarks too
view that left to its own devices the
Taliban would control half of
Afghanistan and the Northern Alliance
certain successors the rest in the
region I covered people say things like
that a lot that I actually don't think
are truth you know there's received
wisdom about how strong Hamas is or how
strong the key a is and people repeated
but there's no evidence for drastically
wrong so I'm curious Michael how you see
their actual natural strengths and
whether it's feasible that they really
could win control the whole country and
then not they have curious from the US
government perspective whether whether
there's what the realistic appraisal of
how strong our allies are there when we
start with GL and work our way down
well I would start with the second
question actually when I said that and I
think I'm not the only one saying that
the Taliban on the nationalist movement
means first that they have no project
outside of again is done I think that's
the most important point I mean say that
it's a revolutionary movement it's a
revolution the Taliban are revolution
and doesn't mean there are moderate
doesn't just that they are fighting for
a certain idea of Afghanistan and fall
state Taliban obsessed by the state and
if there is win important moment in the
history of the Taliban it's 96 when they
take cable and people are speaking a
tree
I spoke also but no Taliban but new
Taliban the will new Terrebonne are
emerging in 96 when they they understand
that they can build a state and they
made a lot of progress from 96 to 2001
to build this state so just to say that
the second is we have always
some conversation but what are the
Taliban are the Taliban is very local
movement local give agreement cease and
so on and it's due to a large part of
home of scale what which scale are you
choosing to analyze that is the the
phenomenon if you thinking at the
district level and most of the military
and US official in general are thinking
at the district level that's very
interesting there is very few
understanding of the national dynamics
and that's why for example in 2008 the
North was supposed to be perfectly okay
why because if the Taliban are local
movement and the Pashtun movement why
should you have a problem in Kunduz
sorry sir and then we see that we have a
big prominent contusion back on in Taha
and so on and so on so the prime of this
local interpretation of the Taliban is
that basically you don't understand why
things are changing from one year to
another area why is the movement
extending all the time if it's local
variances and the problem is that the
Taliban our political movement and
that's the key point yes there is there
is local autonomy to the Taliban
fighters yes okay but it's a political
whatever political ideology so
addressing the local grievances of the
people is not going to solve the
question because maybe you're going to
become Taliban because of local
grievances but when you are inside the
Taliban there is no way back
you have Sarita it is your part of the
political movement so you cannot go back
in time addressing local Indian sees is
never going to work it's like the idea
that okay Taliban fighters mostly
unemployed so we are going to give a job
to every Afghan and then the Taliban
Guzman is going to disappear I'm pushing
a little far but that that's the problem
dividing the country is not technically
possible all you want to what
to to displace two or three million
Pashtun people from the north to the
south it doesn't make sense
the political map is searched today that
the idea that you divide the country and
the novice faith is just wrong the north
of Afghanistan is not stable it's not
safe its Taliban or other group it's
totally out of control
you cannot take a car from Kabul to
conduce that's it so this is totally out
of question
the third point but the the UN the UN
doesn't I mean doesn't have a very good
record in Afghanistan actually at the
beginning the the UN was supposed in a
way to reorganize the country to be kind
of a central player for the State
Building for a lot of things and it did
not work very well because you went
basically doesn't did not have the
resources it doesn't have the resources
today what could be the role of the UN
now the role of the UN is important
because it's a way for the United State
to send somebody negotiate with the
Taliban and very concretely the UN can
give protection to the Taliban
leadership in case of negotiation and in
case of ceasefire and so the UN is a key
player because it could avoid what
nobody wants in Washington means a shake
hand with morale now especially not near
a Clinton so it's a way to defuse the
question of the political sensibilities
and it's extremely useful so it could be
a clip player it's not right now because
there is no support from the United
State for a negotiation and a solution
political solution we are still with the
dream that we can have local solution in
the form we cannot for another reason is
that the Pakistan Pakistan will never
accept local solutions because if you
have local solutions Pakistan is out of
the picture Pakistan will never accept
that you're going to make a deal in
anger you're going to make a deal in
candor are you going to make a deal in
that race and so what's the words where
is the influence of Pakistan so it's not
going to work Pakistan will do
everything to
this kind of local deal and they can do
it trust me if you make a deal right now
to the Karzai government to the u.s.
your life expectancy is yeah you you're
dead basically sink under what's
happening in Canada for this reason I
think that local is not the solution in
Afghanistan well there's a couple of
things one on the the UN negotiating
again I'm speaking in my personal
capacity but the the UN mandate is you
know to support the Afghan government so
you know if they're working with the
Afghan government there there could be a
role the main thing is to avoid the
perception that they're doing something
independently of that mandate they're
you know there can be tensions if people
feel that their world is a neutral role
and therefore they're supposed to
balance equities between an insurgent
group and and the F and the Afghan
government so you know that would just
have to be clearly defined you know by
the Afghan government and and it's its
relation with the with the UN in terms
of you know it's interesting to hear as
you'll say that though you know we are
not looking at the national dynamics so
I you know I know some of the folks in
this audience who worked here seen quite
a lot of attention and focus on the
national dynamics and it's recently that
we've moved out and and had a lot more
attention I wouldn't say district only
although that is a big focus of the
current strategy but it's district and
sub district trying to understand much
more nuance to some of the the sources
and nature of the conflict out there and
what our role might be we have seen you
know in places like the you know Khyber
Pass and up along Kunar some pretty good
contact with the Pakistanis on certain
enemies and and and trade in ways that I
think we can continue to build on so I'm
not as pessimistic as you that Pakistan
will not accept localized solutions they
certainly in
agen dialogue with with their Afghan
counterparts along the border and then I
did appreciate the question on
sustainability of you know development
assistance particularly in villages you
know the main thing on that is we're
probably at a point where we've pumped
in a lot of money and we've
hyper-inflated the economy in a lot of
ways and what we really have to do is
transition to you know Afghan capacity
and folks have referenced it earlier in
this session about you know really a lot
of folks have come over that are
talented and skilled Afghans there now
working for NGOs or they're working for
part you know associated with the
international community effort and and
the idea now is that you know they'll
have to be steered back into the
communities so that they can contribute
you know in ways that are
entrepreneurial in ways that you know
they can they can actually have a more
sustainable grounds and again you know
different things that are being looked
at through legislation in Afghanistan
are you know how to address the the
timber revenue issue and you know how to
address things like gems so that that is
actually on the table in Afghanistan
because they're they're cognizant that
these industries have to be indigenous
and self-sustaining likely of a brief
last word three dots words on the UN the
UN are a bit like the Taliban great
brand Tom they the Taliban brand was the
best brand to organize armed opposition
against the the government the UN is the
best brands to organize these dogs
however they the point is that the the
current brief of the representative of
the secretary-general is to support one
of the warding bull warring parties I
sort see it's slightly different from
Dundee I think there are things that
they the UN country team can do to sort
of prepare the way bit of
confidence-building but we're actually
comes to you know solving at the
national level it's going to be over
their heads and I think you're going to
be requiring
people that go back to the Security
Council and get a separate mandate um
you just and because the dynamics of it
simply do not work that they the
government the administration in Kabul
is part of the problem very much so as
well as been part of the solution
they will not Brook okay any any hint of
independent action they will not
tolerate the country team having the
kind of independence that would be
required to mediate the conflict
successfully so when there is a serious
attempt to get a negotiated solution to
this conflict we will see the Security
Council re-entering the fray and
actually giving some kind of a mandate
for it or whatever they I mean it see if
we can I'd say so it's one of the
different different great religions it's
like the difference between John the
Baptist and the and actually Jesus I
mean John the Baptist very important
role but it's all preliminary the real
thing comes later if I got to compare
them to the tower to the Taliban I can
also give where they just briefed as
well secondly on this on the bit about
the why why iswhat I mean when I say
that they in terms of political ecology
they the Taliban occupy the space that
at other times has been used with beans
are like the clerical wing of of
traditional push to nationalism it's
because if you study what they say and
if you work out what do they think these
things have been said before by other
people you who would have been labeled
so as as such clearly we're of you know
the clerics in Pashto nationalism so if
you looked at the kind of the kind of
stance that one would not be took in the
politics of our understand of the 70s
you'd find very similar stance as to
being taken by the Taliban today
although it's a different it's a
different movement so it's this not
meant to be a value judgment it's about
to be trying to understand what are the
political incidence things was the
continuity in Afghan political themes
reaching over decades even preceding the
current conflict and it's pioneer and
it's important to understand this when
you decide you know should we be CEO
should we be investing 10 million
dollars in killing every one of them or
should be looking for a sort of fresh
approach but then finally and related
related to that on the issue of what's
the natural
how much of Afghanistan can the Taliban
and Taliban expect it depends I don't
think that Taliban in any ways are
naturally the soul the soul you know
political tendency that could mobilize
the questions of Afghanistan in fact if
we were to look back to the to the
earlier stages of the current process
where it might have turned out a bit
differently even if you go to something
like the elections in 2005 down in in
Kandahar and see I'm sorry for looking
away from the from the survey least but
in the in the elections in 2005 that
although there were opportunities for
people associated with the Taliban to
come into it with a repeal foreign
minister one of the best-known Taliban
did not get a look in because people in
Kandahar were organized in a different
way and not organized by the Taliban at
the apt art period and I think that when
you do think in terms of strategies as
to how this is the the the political
capital that Taliban do have could work
as part of this process rather than
against it probably you wouldn't be
looking to them to their to contest or
win elections in those areas I mean if
you look over toward if you look over
towards the east of Afghanistan at the
moment I think it's very interesting
that where you get the sense the the
nearest thing to an almost real
elections in question areas in Nanga in
Nangarhar province this is the heart of
of RC East although we do have a very a
growing and serious insurgency problem
there that they you know those
describing themselves as tan as Taliban
you know yet obviously don't get don't
get a look in that we can get actually
political clans that have emerged out of
the survey out of those to the pre
Taliban politics of the area in terms of
important families important tribes and
important some ethnic groups all have
found representation without having to
reach for the Taliban so yeah if if
questions were united behind one
you know then of course they'd be
grabbing half the country but they you
know you know how much the Taliban can
mobilize depends really on what else is
happening thanks very much